desde la congestión de los puertos y el
alza a los precios hasta la escasez
generalizada la crisis en las cadenas de
suministro en eeuu canadá y otros países
industrializados se intensifica y podría
frenar la recuperación económica por
pandemia en los próximos meses una de
las principales razones de la afectación
de esta cadena es la reactivación
mundial luego de la pandemia y la alta
demanda de compra de las personas la
llamada cadena de suministros es una
función estratégica y logística que
involucra todas las operaciones que son
indispensables para que una mercancía
logre llegar al cliente final en óptimas
condiciones para ello quiero saludar en
este momento a nuestra segunda invitada
del día ella es magdalena base de litio
investigadora post doctorado no el
instituto de derechos humanos y empresas
de la universidad de monterrey en méxico
además doctora en relaciones
internacionales de la universidad
nacional de la plata en argentina
gracias magdalena por estar con nosotros
en france 24
muy buen día vamos a empezar
preguntándole cuáles son las causas de
la escasez de productos y también de la
congestión en los puertos de todo el
mundo
gusto en saludarte raúl un gusto estar
con ustedes una vez más bueno estamos en
medio de una situación en la cual
confluyen diferentes factores por un
lado como bien decía la introducción un
aumento repentino de la demanda
estuvimos más tiempo en casa consumimos
menos servicios
por tanto consumimos más productos
cambiamos los electrodomésticos
cambiamos el vehículo personal porque
priorizamos el transporte personal
privado al transporte público pero por
otro lado hay elementos que tienen que
ver con las relaciones internacionales
por ejemplo la vacunación ha sido lenta
en muchos lugares la vacunación contra
el jove 19 me refiero por tanto los
empleados los funcionarios portuarios y
vinculados al transporte han tenido
contagios y esto determina qué
lentes cano que separen los procesos
portuarios
por otro lado
faltan en conductores de camiones o sea
no sólo pensemos en comercio marítimo en
transporte marítimo sino también esa
mercadería que una vez que llega al
puerto debe ser trasladada por tierra
después tenemos otros elementos más
vinculados a temas económicos
aumentó la demanda subieron los precios
los precios de los fletes
específicamente voy a poner un ejemplo
para que sea más ilustrativo un flete
desde china a uruguaya montevideo previo
a la pandemia más o menos un contenedor
de 40 pies contenedor de los teus de los
grandes vamos a hacerlo así para que se
comprenda fácilmente tenía un costo de
dos mil dólares ahora para una
cotización que se hizo recientemente
para el mes de noviembre
14.000 por tanto aquí podríamos pensar
en el factor de las navieras
pongo son un ejemplo 2020 ha sido uno de
los años que más han facturado de las
navieras por tanto está ese rol ese rol
empresarial
obviamente aprovechando la situación
generando más lucro de la situación pero
con un rol muy polémico más demanda pero
ellos aumentan los precios y podríamos
seguir analizando si ustedes quisieran
ahora magdalena' le pregunté entonces
cuánto puede tardar en resolverse esta
crisis global en toda la cadena de
suministros
bueno a todos nos gustaría saber cuánto
puede tardar justamente en resolverse
este problema si le puedo decir que el
65% de los contenedores en el mundo al
mes de julio que es el último dato que
tengo venían con retraso esto no se
resuelve de la noche a la mañana se
necesitan más buques pero la
construcción de un buque justamente
puede llevar de ahí más o menos dos años
incluso los últimos buques los los más
grandes los que tienen mayor capacidad
han llevado aproximadamente dos años de
construcción
puntualmente en el caso de eeuu que
ustedes lo mencionaba en el comienzo
bailén y elaboró algún paquete de
medidas que presentó no sólo las
empresas sino también a los sindicatos
porque se necesita el apoyo de los
trabajadores en esas medidas
especialmente para descongestionar el
puerto de los ángeles que han llegado a
tener demoras de 60 buques a la espera o
sea el cuello de botella
comenzó a ser muy pequeño dentro de
estas medidas están que se trabajan las
24 horas del día siete días a la semana
ya que nunca descanse el puerto de los
ángeles que los trabajadores acepten
trabajar horas extras y que en el caso
de los camioneros
comiencen a trabajar turnos nocturnos
con todo lo que eso implica un turno
nocturno a nivel de transporte el
carretero mayor peligrosidad mayores
gastos porque obviamente son son
horarios que desde el punto de vista de
los derechos laborales implican un pago
extra cuando vamos a tener una
resolución de este tema aún no no lo
sabemos
pongo un ejemplo más para que veas lo
difícil y lo grave que es este tema en
áreas como puede ser la industria
automotriz hay demoras para un automóvil
de 8 9 meses por tanto aquí tenemos un
factor agregado que si quieren luego lo
lo analizamos se están comenzando a
realizar los pedidos con más
anticipación
y con este desacople de la demanda con
la oferta podemos generar una paradoja
que el día que se acople haya demasiado
oferta para una demanda que se mantuvo
constante magdalena hay también una
pregunta porque hay muchos que dicen que
no es culpa
del cobi 19 si no culpa el capitalismo
la forma como nosotros estamos
consumiendo que cada día es más agresiva
más grande usted cómo lo ve
qué pregunta interesante porque además
es hasta el corte filosófica
y biológica
creo que las pandemias indem ya por hoy
19 tiene un el agua agregó un elemento
fundamental pero también el aumento en
el consumo
especialmente en estas fechas
no es fortuito que byd en justamente en
este momento esté tomando nuevas medidas
y medidas tan drásticas como pedir que
un puerto trabaje las 24 horas del día
te acerca la navidad y es un momento de
mucho consumo y de mucho consumo de
juguetes no es
no es fortuito tampoco que justamente
esa industria sea una de las más
afectadas más afectadas porque sus
componentes se fabrican en diferentes
lugares del mundo cada uno de éstos ha
tenido paradas en la producción
a su vez sumamos el problema de los
transportes el enlentecimiento el
aumento del costo de los fletes y
siempre es el bolsillo del consumidor el
que termina pagando estas diferencias si
es la joven 19 o es el capitalismo bueno
pensemos que hay una mezcla de ambos y
también ese extractivismo y esa relación
con la naturaleza que el propio sistema
capitalista genera tiene mucho que ver
con esta pandemia sin demián la que
estamos viviendo magdalena' muy
rápidamente 30 segunditos navidad
amenaza
en parte si las industrias de juguetes
dicen que no porque hay otras opciones
pero en parte sí que todo lo que tenga
que ver con teléfonos celulares
electrodomésticos que sean microchips
probablemente los pedidos lleguen más
tarde o haya que comprar un producto
sustitutivo